tom considering that you're the one in
charge of this shoe um why did you make
us do jousting
it's not so much that i'm in charge of
this is that at some point in the last
few weeks someone on the team said hey
tom how about jousting i went yeah sure
i'm
now it's happening now it's happening
i'm not sure how i feel about it to be
honest i've never i've never ridden a
horse thrilled excited yeah nervous i
don't think we're going to throw it i
don't think we'll be asking each other i
think this is this is a tournament this
is a competition okay i'm out of here
because i was mainly here for the bodily
harm towards you
oh my god they're so big
i i nearly said that i thought is it is
that too obvious just like i don't think
i've ever
been close to a horse in my life i've
seen horses like i don't want to sound
stupid here i've seen i've never been
close
but when you have it's never been when
you're about to get on top of it and to
be the height of the back of a horse
yeah which suddenly makes them look like
the tallest animals that have ever
existed hello
all right guys so these are your horses
for the day so tom you will be riding
freddie all right for the day hello
so what we will do is we'll get you both
mounted up adjust the stirrup level for
you both
and then we'll crack on all right let's
go
you've done this once before right yeah
one time yeah is there a knack to this
yeah so i'll talk you through it as we
as we get to it see you giggling there
you've got to do this in a minute as
well it's good that you're going first
because all i have to do is be better
than you are getting on the horse and
then it'll be fine you're going to place
your left foot into this stirrup all
right yeah and then hold the front and
the back of the saddle hold the front of
the left side second i'll just hold this
step of course the stirrup moves i just
and you're going to swing your right leg
over the back of the horse
that's it perfect okay well that yep
thank you
that was beautifully done right into
this very well done
probably so that is i just took that all
right if you just sorry i'm just gonna
pop that do you feel one with the horse
tom
no no not at all uh i i am i am on the
horse
more than that
i'm not just not
we'll ask you again at the end see if
you formed a lasting friendship yep so
you're going to have your left ring
between your thumb and your first finger
and your right rein between your first
and second thing okay yeah these horses
are trying to neck grain so effectively
taking your hand up the neck is like
taking your handbrake off
and then
that's the analogy i've got that's fine
so you take your handbrake off and then
you give it a little bit of gas so
that's with you with your all right as
soon as he's took off then you
completely relax your legs off him yep
because the more pressure you put on him
the faster he's gonna want to go right
okay yep and then when you want to go
left you're simply going to take so with
your hand still up at his neck you will
take your hand over to the left he will
feel this neck this round on his neck
and he will respond away from it so the
higher up the neck he feels that the
more responsive that's going to be so
that's the same for left and for right
and then when you wish to stop you're
simply going to bring your hand into
your belt buckle and he'll these rounds
are connected to this bit in his mouth
and that's going to tell him that you
want him to slow down okay i think i can
remember all that you got all that as
well ron
so i am a lesbian and therefore don't
drive so there are analogies
i've done the legoland races but they
didn't have a handbrake but i think i'm
puzzling it out okay at the same time
okay ryan if you'd like to
we're going to get introduce you to toby
hello toby just step over here for me
and make your way around onto the steps
to the top step
okay and you're going to put your left
foot in this stirrup got it and then
swing your right leg over
perfect
feeling okay feeling good right then
let's get these horses moving
while swiss stud's still here together i
just want to go through some of the
motions that you're going to feel when
we move from walking into trot so what
i'd like you to do is when we trot we do
what's called a rising truck so as the
horse moves it's got a natural up and
down rise and fall movement so you will
then have to kind of counteract that by
controlling your own rise and your fall
so that we take out the bounce element
on the horse's back and it just keeps
them more comfortable and enables you
guys to then focus on the skills that
we're going to introduce you to so we
should just do that again so like up and
down up and down up so right let's get
these horses warmed up and then we'll go
through a little bit more the riding
elements with yourselves and then we'll
crack straight on with some skills okay
okay then
i am just going to send you off just to
have a little trot next to you we're
going to rumble alongside you
and really just get you to get feel that
rise and fall that we talked about
earlier
[Music]
up
i feel like i'm out of phase here i feel
like i'm
doing the opposite of what's needed here
just think about
pushing all that weight through into
through your legs into the balls of your
feet and keeping your shoulders back yep
and your chin up
your right hand away from the saddle yep
and then taking that bounce out of the
truck okay a lot to think about all
right but i'm sure you can do it
okay let's go again so hand forward
slightly that forward kick on a little
kick on yeah
that's it so we're gonna go up down up
down up down up down up down right yeah
this looks
a lot better just keep
yourself set your way
yeah
god damn it all right
i should be able to nail the timing on
this and i can't
toby babes i don't know if i've got the
core strength for this but we're gonna
see it through together
all right then let's go so i'm gonna
control the speed of the horse for now
sure
come on there we go so you're gonna go
up down up down up
up down so control that ball
as much as you're pushing out
i feel like i'm at the wrong rhythm okay
so kick him on again give him a good
squeeze with your feet
up down
yeah you've got it
that's it nice
yeah they're really good
there we go okay
really nice
so you've got now the basics sure have
the the real basics okay so we're going
to crack on with some skills and we'll
face it as we go along let's go awesome
how are you doing on the trot um i don't
know i was just sort of bouncing around
and apparently it was good so oh you're
doing better than me then i cannot
cannot nail the timing on this i've just
have to keep
keep trying it there'll be plenty of
time for practice throughout the day
yeah we'll be fine so i'm gonna get a
ring glance and explain to you what your
first skill is going sure
now i'm left hanging i'm being left
hanging oh sorry
oh no that wasn't very inner cowboy with
me
so guys these are your ring lances we
are going to use these for your first
skill which is the lansing of the gold
rings so as you see along the tilt we
have our crown rings i when i hand you
these lances you will hold them in your
right hand we're going to take them away
from our body down to a horizontal
position
up into that armpit and hug that your
elbow into your hips take them from the
right hand side up and over the horse's
head to the left-hand side once you've
got your first ring do not move your
lance anywhere and there's no reason why
you should not then get your second ring
no reason at all
yes are you ready to give it a go we'll
give it a go i feel ridiculously
underqualified for this let's let's go
how are you feeling
great um my handout coordination is such
that i
uh i'm sure that i will get not one but
two rings as well so confidently
predicted that we would be able to do
sure i'll be fine how about you how are
you feeling
this is i am i am not comfortable right
now this does not feel like a thing i
i'm capable of doing we'll uh we'll see
how it goes
give it a give it a go yep yep that's
all we can do is try
so i want you to bring that lance down
between me and the horse that's it get
it up into that armpit got it right and
now track it up and over his head
so look directly through that ring
and then make minor adjustments with
that hand
oh god okay
come on toby
i won't let you down
there we go
okay so when you're ready bring your
lance down right
lung lance goes down yeah lance down
up and over the horse up and over the
horse's head look directly through those
right through the ring and
collect it hey okay number two line it
up
i nearly got the camera lens mind
no
[Music]
come on
[Music]
well we tried toby
[Music]
no
i'm getting worse
oh okay
[Music]
oh
what was that all about then what was
that
there's something up there that you
didn't like you okay yeah i'm okay you
feel okay yeah
tell me we got that on camera a little
bit of adrenaline there at the end yep
there was uh i don't know if it'll i
don't know if the microphone will cover
it there was a loud noise behind and uh
someone got a little bit startled there
you
yes
yeah
so guys our next strength is going to be
the striking of the quintan now this
here is our quintone it is a wooden
man-shaped target used to test the
knight's accuracy and on the shield and
strength uh the combined strength of the
rider and the horse
so what we would like you to do is
shortly we're going to hand you a
quintan lance so very much like your
ring lances if you don't have it couched
in properly on impact that lance is
going to pop out from your armpit and we
can do
one of many things but one is to to
effectively clothesline yourself off the
back of the horse i don't know why i'm
laughing that's terrifying
now so the idea being that you're going
to hit this part of this the quintan and
it is going to spin round
now the the more you continue moving
past it the less likely you are to get
hit by them
so
when these would have been used back in
medieval times this would have had a
really heavy spiky ball on and if you
didn't strike the quintan properly or
you didn't continue your ride away from
the quintane you would get a punishment
of being hit by the ball right then are
we ready to start
oh good to go
okay so you're gonna aim for that top
right hand part of the shield yeah
and we don't fall we just let it hit
there we go
that is keep getting forward really
squeeze
so keep that shoulders back yep
nice really nice here
up down up down
come keep going keep kicking keep
kicking here we go top right hand corner
yes
wrong way
you're good
yes keep going toby come on and
yes
i was convinced that flail was about to
hit my head there
[Music]
keep going
come on come on come on come on come on
yes
all right so that is all of your
training done for this morning we're
gonna break for a minute and collect
ourselves have a bit of lunch and then
we're gonna come back out here for the
grand gauntlet challenge huzzah
so at any point that you hear me say the
grand gauntlet challenges are you will
follow it with a big renowned in huzzah
so we're going to try that once more
once i have taken these lances from you
this is like it's too dangerous with the
lancers let's give this one exactly the
sort of thing that i am immediately
cynical about it's going to it's going
to take a while for me to warm up to to
get getting the word in there so let's
try this again when we return after
lunch we are going to partake in what we
call the grand gauntlet challenge
very good there's still a layer of irony
on that for me i
yeah we need full commitment this
afternoon so this afternoon we are going
to combine all the skills you have
learnt this morning and we're going to
put it into a one after the other
challenge you will be competing against
each other for this and there's a little
surprise in store at the end of the day
but you will be in full nightly gear
this afternoon so let's go take a break
now get ourselves and horses into
costume and we will come back out here
shortly
i saved about 400 pounds on renting this
car thanks to nordvpn seriously i'm on
the road a lot at the moment and it
turns out that things like car rental
are sometimes priced differently not
based on who you are not on how well you
drive not on where your billing address
is but instead where the company's
website thinks you are because i was
able to use the magic nordvpn button on
my laptop and phone that told the rental
place i'm still in the uk i saved over a
third of what this rental would have
cost i don't know why maybe i could have
saved more if i'd picked a different one
of the 60 or so countries that nordvpn
supports but i was happy enough with
that plus that magic button means i can
access content that's geo locked like
i'm trying to do research and a us news
site blocks all europeans because they
can't be bothered to comply with the
local privacy laws which happens to be a
surprising amount when i'm in europe
although if you are gonna try that with
streaming video check the services terms
and conditions first you can use nordvpn
on six devices at the same time it's
never slowed down my browsing it's
lightning fast far as i can tell and if
it turns out not to work for you no
bother there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee if you go to nordvpn.com tomsk
plus you'll find the best deal they're
currently offering right back to the
horsing around
[Music]
[Music]
we look great i think we look fantastic
very professional
will will looks fantastic will has hair
and kate flowing in the breeze beautiful
we look like uh contestants in a game
show who are about to get like gunshots
we've got we've got the the mic on here
and everything is it's a strong look
yeah
[Music]
okay welcome knights so we are now ready
to start the grand gauntlet challenge
so we're going to get you mounted up and
then we're going to see who's going to
be have it this afternoon
right then let's go so we're going to
start off with the collection of the
gold rings that each ring is worth one
point so there's four points available
on the tilt then we will strike the
quintan once in each direction another
point available for a good strong solid
hit on the quintin so a total of six
points available for you here are we
ready
yes right then let's go you ready yep
come on come on off we go
okay so first up to ride we have
lady rowan the radiant
okay when you're ready my lady you shall
ride
[Music]
she's got it
hey she's got it
[Music]
not on that one come on
okay two
and it's
it goes up and it's really tight
okay cool
ready okay come on toby we can do it
got it
that's a solid hit
and she was going fast enough to be past
the uh the flail as well
there we go so next up to ride we have
thomas the
when you uncertain
ready my lord please ride
all right
here we go go trot on
come on come on come on no
yes that's one that's one that's whoa
whoa whoa whoa
here we go oh
come on come on come on no
and i lost a stirrup as well
come on come on come on
yes yes two points well done
so that's a total of two points for the
quintan and one point from the rings
i was trying
so damn hard on that last ring you did
really well though i mean not quite as
well milady i hate to say that it sounds
wrong but uh
just
off your little fedora to me thank you
so much right then guys so the end of
that challenge rowan you're on four
points and tom you had three meaning
rowan you are the winner of our grand
gauntlet challenge
which means that today you get to joust
against the real life night of middle
england
let's do it good luck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes we did a thing
and i assume i hit him because we
definitely didn't script it that way
thank you so much squire
how was that
that was great that was so fun
i definitely uh hit him which is in the
aim of the game so i'm feeling
victorious from that point of view thank
you so much for coming down thank you
for inviting me i did not realize at the
start of the day i would end it as a
night but you've given me the
opportunity and for that i can only
thank you
perfect
you